well there's so much i want to say to
you in four minutes because you
the ability for you to just start crying
from clenching your hands to those
insecure smiles you did a brilliant job
bringing michelle alive so kudos to you
because it is
pretty powerful what you did
um
we know this story and you kind of
relive this story and you kind of have
more of an understanding who she is so
in your words who is michelle carter to
you now
i think i mean that's that's hard to say
i i think our series
we don't seek out
um
um to answer all of the questions i
think there's still you know
answers that we will never know um and
holes that we did kind of have to to
fill but at the same time
i do think the media portrayed this
story in a very
you know one way um back when it was all
happening and
and you know they wanted michelle was
kind of this they portrayed her as this
you know black widow
manipulative um very like one note one
dimensional and also on conrad's side i
mean he was the victim in this um
and it the story ended in the most
tragic way that it could but we didn't
get to learn anything about
his life or his background or who he was
as a young man
um and i think that that was something
that really drew me to towards the case
i mean i was kind of riveted by it
like the world was i mean i was a lot
younger but i do remember
hearing about it and hearing about just
remembering what a unique case it was
because it's such a modern case it could
only happen today because it's all about
technology and how we relate to
technology and being a young person
myself i'm addicted to my phone and and
that instant gratification and false
sense of reality sometimes that we all
can easily slip into
was so interesting to me um but i do
feel you know a greater understanding of
michelle and what she was going through
at the time as well and i hope this
series kind of doesn't sensationalize it
but just shows the story and from you
know an unbiased perspective yeah and
you bring up a good point about the
digital era and how do you keep your
mind out of it how do you keep yourself
sane from everything that's on social
media
it's hard i don't think yeah the answer
i mean i feel like if someone did they
would you know they would have the
golden ticket like in life did you let
it get to you do you kind of know how to
just kind of let it be
i mean you have to
of course you do you can go down rabbit
holes and of comparing yourself to other
people it's so easy because there's so
many images in our face all the time of
this
perfection that you know this
unattainable perfection i think that all
of us see all the time
um so of course you can't help it but
you have to try to
just keep yourself centered on who you
are and
and
you know be happy with
with what you have and bring the gifts
that you have um but of course
i mean i think we all have those days of
that
you know what one of the story that is
so important in this is her fascination
with glee and you have that powerful
performance in front of the mirror and
you're singing the song make you feel my
love and
do you think do you believe that she was
trying to make leah michelle and cory
monteith her reality
i think that
what the series does as well and kind of
what was going on in our version of
michelle that we wrote was this blurred
line like a blurred sense of reality
and
and fantasy um you know we have kind of
these fantasy numbers also in our show
and i think as a young person it's so
easy to
place yourself in daydream and put
yourself as the star in these y.a
you know
shows and movies that you watch when
you're young and it's really easy to
slip into that and i mean as an actor
i'm someone that is living in fantasy
world all the time so i can kind of
understand um yeah that that scene was
really fascinating to do it was very
challenging i watched glee while filming
um i hadn't i watched a bit bef you know
when it was on but not as much as i had
for this um and i that clip i've seen so
countless times but it's very meta
because obviously you know lea michelle
is
mourning the loss of her real real-life
boyfriend but also
mourning him on the show and then
michelle my michelle is trying to mimic
her grief in a way and i think that's
the one moment where in the pilot it
kind of
turns and the audience starts to
question if this is
her if this is real or if it's something
she's creating so we don't want to
answer that question but i do think that
i don't know it's easy for a lot of
people to kind of
get lost in those narratives because
it's it's very romanticized you know but
by we didn't want to romanticize the
subject matter in any way on our show
even though
i think our character sometimes is
romanticizing it so it's very as
interesting as you know a lot of layers
i'm so fascinated by this and fascinated
by you and i can't wait for everyone to
see this congratulations to you and your
performance it was absolutely brilliant
you